hello everyone just wanted to give
another quick tip on how to use your
files effectively and do some pca
scatterplots
so let's take a look today at two
examples so here i've opened two files
one is a marked one and another one is
just the gene expression table now this
is a small example but you'll get the
idea I guess so let's go back over here
and let's open up unsupervised analysis
as you remember BCA draw draws a
scatterplot using PCA analysis of your
expression values for example so now
let's go back and let's take a look over
here now what you see over here is ID of
the gene and over here you've got sample
names now these are cell lines and so
you've got these abbreviations for them
but look over here now we added this
other row called group and now you've
got this name of a group and you've got
normal like basil luminol cloud and low
etc now let's check this out let's go
over here let's upload one of these
files
okay so let's first of all go into
unsupervised and let's try without the
mark genes okay so let's go to continue
start PC a draw let's change this to two
and do save and then end all right so
now this is going to be PC a draw
unmarked okay and let's save this and
run this pipeline and then the second
one we will create exactly the same
thing and will instead upload the marked
one okay the one that has the group on
it let's do continue start okay again PC
a draw its changes to two and and all
right now we'll call this PC a draw
marked okay
run pipeline
alright let's go to my pipelines and now
you see that both of them are processing
and let's take a look what happens when
they're done all right now take a look I
already got a notification over here in
my mail that these have finished as you
can just click right here and I will go
straight into download and let's look at
the plots alright so here's the plot now
let's see this one as you can see
already shows the grouping with their
name now let's take a look at the other
one let's go to my pipelines and let's
go to the unmarked and see what the
difference is so now let's take at this
take a look at this plot is the same
picture but it's got all the names of
these files and we don't know which
group they're in okay so that's how it's
useful let's just see them side by side
again okay and so you can see what the
difference is you can see that the
difference is going to be between group
or the same scatterplot but this one is
organized and labeled by group and this
is organized and labeled by sample name
that's it next time we'll talk about how
to use this PCA and understand what is
inside the groups how are those gene
expressions different